hey everyone this is phil lord i'm here
with byron my name is byron himmel i am
a 2021 academy nickel fellow and my
script shade of the grapefruit tree is
about a severely abused white boy with a
murderous stepdad and then his black
landlady who is obsessed with science
fiction and she teaches him to behave
like a robot which empowers him to
confront the bad stepdad
oh there he is what's happening what's
up man hey really nice to meet you nice
to meet you too i've read your bio and
you've taken a pretty circuitous route
to professional screenwriting
it was like i did all these other things
to eventually make movies things like
journalism i was an associate producer
for radio i was in a band i was a
professional actor for a little bit it
all applies i love that contrast you
grow up in the projects but then you go
to a fancy art school this has been my
life like i love beauty and like
hardship just boom boom you had all
these details that were just seemed like
they were things that you experienced
yourself well these were real people you
know i based it on the real people and
real events in my life i mean i didn't
literally become a robot
in in my real life so far yeah so far
i'm working on it
how long ago did you start writing that
script it was uh this time last year
actually do you write fast it really
varies like it's it's months at a time
my first drafts that come out i want it
to be very pleasing to me does it make
my chest go
does it seize me up yeah am i gonna cry
the writer is that a big part of your
writing process that you revise heavily
i mean my first draft is always
garbage same here i'm a great editor
actually and that's where i shine so if
i make garbage it's okay i can change it
i don't have the bone anymore that that
says oh i feel hurt by your comment you
have to have a lot of humility because
the movie wants what it wants i
write with a partner all the time and i
learned not to
argue with him about his response to it
and only to try to engage on like the
problem solving and that gets really fun
because when you've got two people in a
room kicking ideas around you always
come up with something that neither of
you could have done on your own yep
because you create a whole new entity
it's it's it's not you it's not him or
her it's like the two of you together
you're something else my girlfriend who
really is my creative partner in
everything it is that partnership that
makes me find the magic moments because
i didn't want to write drama i wanted to
do uh genre stuff because i have all
these scenes that would be horribly
traumatic to put a child actor through i
don't want to be a person who some child
remembers and hates you know because i
put them through that yeah like i've
often been to movies where i'm like i'm
being punished and i thought that you
found a way without pulling any punches
to show how difficult the situation was
but alongside it you know this is what
evil looks like but this is also what
goodness looks like
the script really is about the tiny
small things that a person can do to
help someone who's going through it
somebody told me when i moved to la
follow the green lights
and i always try to remember that when
something comes into your eye line pay
attention you know opportunities like
this where i get to talk to you
are selfishly really enlightening for me
so i'm i get a lot out of that it's
really inspiring
reading your this work it opens up our
writing me and chris when we start to
think okay what if everybody in this
scene had good intentions you've been
invited into somebody's brain
so you want to leave you want to be
proud of what you're leaving
you know now you're going to be in the
position where people are going to ask
you like what helped your writing turn
the corner i'm 100
right completely from your heart then
worry about how it fits with with
everyone else later something i try to
do more often is embrace whatever
enters your head because it's probably
you're the only guy who's gonna that's
gonna occur to you it's the only way to
tell a story that no one else can tell
and that is how i found my voice with
this script it's funny that it's the the
thing that broke through for you is the
most personal it is
well done well we'll see around the
campus i'm sure and godspeed
do some more please i will i am
you